bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
émission minutes forme aussi nicolas
votre coach jeune homme en compagnie
d'anaïs bonjour à nice comment vas tu la
respectes en forme aujourd'hui ça va on
va voir ensemble aujourd'hui le
mouvement de l'extension du dos pour
renforcer tout votre chaîne postérieur
vous permet d'avoir une meilleure
posture dans la vie quotidienne dans un
premier temps je vais vous l'expliquer à
nice je te le démontrer et derrière tu
vas leur produirait tôt que je te
corriger sur certains petits détails
si tu fais des petites erreurs derrière
vous pouvez effectuer ce mouvement soit
des séries assez longue
entre 15 et 30 répétition va les voir
pour bien renforcer derrière avec des
récupérations cours on y va venez vous
installer sur le ventre vous allonger
les jambes tousse et les orteils le plus
loin possible derrière vous contractez
volontairement vos fessiers la poitrine
sur le sol vous avez un premier niveau
vous placez vos mains au niveau du front
le visage contre le sol et vous aller
soulever la poitrine le plus haut
possible
vraiment sentir la zone lombaire bosser
ou descendez vous montez vous soulevez
le plus haut possible
un deuxième niveau de difficulté vous
pouvez ouvrir les mains il levait le
buste rapprocher un peu plus les
omoplates et gainé et là vous allez
transférer également le exercice sur le
haut du dos à l'install toi sur le
ventre à l'ange légende du ser
volontairement les fessiers tu viens
plaquer le ventre sur le tapis les mains
contre le front et là tu vas essayer de
décoller très très haute à poitrine pour
venir contracté cette zone lamberth
aller à twilight très très bien je m'en
fais une petite quinzaine partait sur
une quinzaine
vous allez vraiment sentir ça va
chauffer ici expiré en montant vous
inspirer en descendant tu m'en fais
encore quatre à l'e3
2 un parfait tu poses de maïs comment tu
te sens tu as bien senti au niveau du
dos nous allons voir maintenant
l'étirement qui correspond à cet
exercice allonge les orteils tu peut
allonger les orteils sur le sol voilà
mostefaï sur tes talons et tu va
allonger les bras elle va essayer
d'aller le plus loin possible on
vraiment étiré toute la colonne
vertébrale relâche la nuque regarde le
sol pense à respirer profondément
et tu peu relâché remonte doucement
voilà pour les tirs mans du dos si vous
voulez voir d'autres étirements rendez
vous sur les prochains numéros de munich
forme merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
merci à nice
je vous souhaite une très très bonne
journée à très bientôt
extension du dow perd deux à trois fois
par semaine de trois à six séries 15 à
30 répétition
attention aux mauvais positionnement de
la tête